Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Teenagers are pampered with high wages, first-class working conditions and excellent facilities in education. Their outlook is centred in trashy books and films. The boys are hoodlums in embryo, defiant and uncouth, while the girls are brazen and unrefined a rigorous period of military training might make men and women of them if they had the courage to face it welcome to the rest is history and our subject today is of course teenagers so tom holland you're a man who i always associate with youth culture and with teenage brio so here's a question emails dominic sandbrook here's a
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。青少年们被高薪、一流的工作环境以及优越的教育设施娇惯着。他们的眼光局限于低俗的书籍和电影。男孩们是未成熟的暴徒，叛逆且粗俗，而女孩们则厚颜无耻、缺乏教养。如果他们有勇气面对的话，一段严格的军事训练可能会让他们真正成为男子汉和女中豪杰。欢迎来到《历史的余烬》，我们今天的主题当然是青少年。所以，汤姆·霍兰德，你是一个我总是将其与青年文化和青春活力联系在一起的人，所以有个问题，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克发来一封邮件，这里有一个
question for you um when do you think that's from that quote okay well it mentions teenagers yes and i know that the word teenager is a recent invention 1944 yeah it is nice in america yeah 1944 in america so it must be after that. Yeah. Reference to military service. If it's Britain. This is a top historian at work using forensic skills. So perhaps after the end of conscription. So is this a reference to Beatlemania?
问题想问你，嗯，你觉得这段话出自哪里？好吧，它提到了青少年，是的，我知道“青少年”（teenager）这个词是一个最近才发明的词，1944年，是的，没错，是在美国，是的，1944年在美国，所以肯定是在那之后。是的。提到了兵役。如果是在英国的话。这是一位顶级的历史学家正在运用其刑侦般的技能进行分析。所以也许是在征兵制结束之后？那么这是在指“披头士狂热”（Beatlemania）吗？
1963? Good guess. Good guess. 1963. Good guess, but wrong. It's 1949. Goodness. It's quite early. That is early.
1963年？猜得不错。猜得不错。1963年。猜得不错，但猜错了。是1949年。天哪。这相当早。这确实很早。
Can you guess the publication? Is it British? It is British. Publication? Daily Mail. It is the Daily Mail. Is it? It is the Daily Mail in 1943.
你能猜出是哪个出版物吗？它是英国的吗？它是英国的。出版物？《每日邮报》。是《每日邮报》。是吗？那是1943年的《每日邮报》。
Finger on the pulse of fashion as ever. It's actually a reader's letter. And who is the reader? Colonel. Colonel. Yeah, exactly. Bufton. No, that's a telegraph. is the reader? Colonel. Yeah, exactly. Bufton. No, that's a telegraph.
一如既往地敏锐捕捉时尚脉搏。这其实是一封读者来信。那么这位读者是谁呢？上校。上校。是的，没错。巴夫顿（Bufton）。不，那是《每日电讯报》。这位读者是谁？上校。是的，没错。巴夫顿。不，那是《每日电讯报》。
That's not the man. Yeah, that's all right. It would be Colonel Tufton's wife. No, it's interesting how early that is. Because as you say, the teenager is invented in 1944. But I suppose anxieties about young people are as old as history itself, aren't they? I mean, every point you look in human history, people are always complaining that the young have no morals. Yeah, but is the young equivalent to a teenager?
那不是那个人。是的，没关系。那大概是巴夫顿上校的妻子吧。不，有趣的是这时间竟然这么早。因为正如你所说，“青少年”这个词是在1944年才被发明的。但我想，人们对年轻人的焦虑和历史本身一样古老，不是吗？我的意思是，纵观人类历史的每一个时期，人们总是在抱怨年轻人没有道德。是的，但“年轻人”等同于“青少年”吗？
Well, this is what I want to get into. Because that's the big question, isn't it? Yeah. So you're right. I think it is 1944 that the teenager is invented, but young people have always existed. And I have no sense, actually. I have no sense at all of what a 14-year-old did in Rome or Greece or the periods you write about.
好吧，这正是我想要探讨的。因为这才是核心问题，对吧？是的。所以你说得对。我想“青少年”确实是在1944年被发明的，但年轻人一直都存在。而且我其实完全无法想象，在罗马、希腊或你所研究的那些时期，一个14岁的孩子究竟在做些什么。
So explain, were there teenagers in those days? There must have been in some sense. Well, we have a question from Joseph Evans Green, who asks, Is the idea of a period between childhood and adulthood a modern invention? And is there any similar idea in the ancient world? And that's really the key question, isn't it? Because teenagers, it's an extended process of coming of age. And I think it'd be fair to say that, I'm going to admit this isn't something I've studied with any great attention, but I would say that by and large, the idea is that you come of age so you have coming of age rituals yeah um i mean in rome you it's it's just the toga you put on shave your beard yes you
所以请解释一下，那个时代有青少年吗？某种意义上肯定有吧。嗯，我们收到了约瑟夫·埃文斯·格林（Joseph Evans Green）的一个问题，他问：童年和成年之间的过渡期这个概念，是一个现代发明吗？古代世界有类似的概念吗？这确实是关键问题，对吧？因为青少年期是一个漫长的成年过渡过程。我觉得可以这样说——我承认这不是我曾深入研究过的课题——但我会说，大体上的观念是你要长大成人，所以会有成年礼。是的，嗯，在罗马，这很简单，就是穿上托加袍，剃掉胡须，是的，
present your beard your first shavings you um you get given you put aside the toga of youth and you put on the toga of manhood um if you're a girl and it's much earlier with girl so you you hand over your doll and a thing called a bulla, which you wore around your neck, which is a kind of charm, symbol of childhood. But having said that, adolescence comes from a Latin word, adolescentia. But adolescentia is kind of basically, it's from the age of 15 up to early 30s.
展示你的胡须，你第一次刮胡子。你，你被授予，你脱下了少年的托加袍，穿上了成年的托加袍。嗯，如果你是个女孩，女孩子的成年仪式要早得多，所以你要交出你的洋娃娃，还有一个叫做“布拉”（bulla）的东西，那是你挂在脖子上的某种护身符，是童年的象征。话虽如此，青春期（adolescence）这个词源于一个拉丁词“adolescentia”。但“adolescentia”基本上是指从15岁到30岁出头的这段时期。
Wow, that's a long adolescence. So there is a kind of, the Romans do have a sense. I mean, particularly in the Republic, youth is looked on with considerable suspicion. So the Romans were a daily male letter writers. They were. The Roman Republic was very daily male. You don't really become a proper adult till your late 30s.
哇，那可真是个漫长的青春期。所以确实有这样一种，罗马人确实有这种概念。我的意思是，尤其是在共和国时期，人们对青年时期抱有相当大的戒心。所以罗马人就是《每日邮报》的读者原型。他们确实是。罗马共和国非常具有《每日邮报》的风格。直到快四十岁时，你才真正成为一个成熟的成年人。
For instance, you can't run for the consulship till you're 40. And you think of all those portrait busts of Roman emperors. Sorry, absolutely, Freudian slip there. Not of Roman emperors, of Roman dignitaries from the Republican era. Ages prized. They all have crow's feet and baggy jowls. But that's such a strange thing, Tom. When so many, you're much more likely to die young.
例如，不到40岁你不能竞选执政官。你想想罗马皇帝的所有那些肖像半身像——抱歉，绝对是弗洛伊德式的口误。不是罗马皇帝，而是共和时代的罗马显贵。老年备受推崇。他们都有鱼尾纹和松弛的下巴。但汤姆，这太奇怪了。当时有那么多人，你更有可能在年轻时就夭折。
So in other words, you're saying people, lots of people who die, who live what to us would be into adulthood, they're not, they die before they're considered full adults in Rome. Yeah, a lot of them. Because they die at the age of 28 or 31 or something. I think, I mean, certainly the Greeks as well
换句话说，你是说人们，许多死去的人——他们活到了我们看来已经是成年人的年纪——但他们其实不是，他们在罗马被视为真正的成年人之前就去世了。是的，很多人。因为他们在28岁或31岁左右就去世了。我想，我的意思是，希腊人当然也是如此。
and the Romans have a sense that um children have to be shaped and molded and toughened up to become worthy of the citizenship that is going to be theirs yeah um and in greece by and large this is done as a kind of civic thing so in sparta famously you have barracks um in athens you have um the afiboi who are it's a kind of military service so that the city is doing it in rome much more the sense is that um it's up to the individual it's well the father has incredible power so he has uh the patria potestas which means that he can kill a son if he gives him any grief i mean essentially from a teenager you can literally kill him um and and the father has this kind of incredible authority um but that
罗马人也有这样一种观念：嗯，必须塑造和雕琢儿童，让他们变得坚韧，从而配得上终将属于他们的公民身份。是的。嗯，在希腊，这大体上是通过一种公民活动来实现的。所以在斯巴达，如人们所知，有军营；在雅典，有“阿费博伊”（efiboi），这是一种兵役制度，是城邦在做这件事。而在罗马，更多的一种观念是：嗯，这取决于个人，而且父亲拥有不可思议的权力。所以他拥有“父权”（patria potestas），这意味着如果儿子惹他生气，他可以杀死儿子。我的意思是，基本上对于一个青少年，他 literalmente 可以杀了儿子。而且父亲拥有这种极其惊人的权威。但
is something that is not tied to kind of teenage years so there's a kind of amazing thing when when the romans are very into adopting so if you want to pass on your patrimony to to someone you adopt someone and the classic example of this is when Augustus is forced to adopt his stepson Tiberius, because there's no other possible heir to the empire. And Tiberius, who at the time is Rome's greatest general, he's a distinguished statesman. He's held all the magistracies. He's a man of incredible sophistication and learning. He's fabulously wealthy. When he gets adopted by Augustus, he loses everything. He becomes dependent for basically kind of an allowance, kind of equivalent to a teenage allowance.
这并不是与所谓的“青少年时期”绑定在一起的。所以有一种奇妙的现象：当罗马人非常热衷于收养时，如果你想把你的祖产传给某人，你就会收养某人。最典型的例子就是屋大维被迫收养他的继子提比略，因为帝国没有其他可能的继承人了。而提比略当时是罗马最伟大的将军，他是一位杰出的政治家。他担任过所有的崇高职位。他是一个极其老练、博学且富可敌国的人。当他被屋大维收养时，他失去了一切。他的生计基本上要依赖一笔津贴，某种程度上相当于青少年的零花钱。
Does Augustus give him pocket money? Yeah, Augustus gives him pocket money. So the sense of generational divide there is really, really strong. And I think a key part of it is that, specifically on the angle of youth, is that when you come of age, it's also that you become sexually in control of your life. Yeah. So the risk is constantly that before you become an adult, so before you come of age, you are going to be subject to all kinds of advances, whether you are male or female.
屋大维会给他零花钱吗？对，屋大维会给他零花钱。所以那种代际鸿沟的感觉在那里真的非常、非常强烈。我认为其中的一个关键部分，特别是从青年的角度来看，就是当你成年时，这也意味着你开始在性方面对自己的生活拥有自主权。是的。所以风险始终在于，在你成为成年人之前，也就是在你成年之前，无论你是男是女，你都会面临各种各样的追求。
And I guess that for girls, the big difference is that essentially you come of age when you're able to conceive. And that's a lot earlier than. So what's that? I mean, yeah, 13 or so. Well, Juliet, Juliet and Romeo and Juliet is 12, isn't she? Yeah. So a girl at that point is considered, they're considered an adult. They're a woman.
我想对于女孩来说，最大的区别基本上是当你具备生育能力时你就成年了。那要早得多。所以那是多大？我的意思是，是的，13岁左右吧。朱丽叶，《罗密欧与朱丽叶》里的朱丽叶才12岁，对吧？是的。所以那个时期的女孩就被认为是成年人了。她们是个女人。
Yes. Yes. And there's no sense, so there's no sense of a kind of a youth, I mean, a youth culture, the expression comes from 1942, so this is projecting way back. But there's no sense of a, what we would call a youth culture, the expression comes from 1942. So this is projecting way back. But there's no sense of a, what we would call a youth culture among Roman teenagers, is there? There's definitely a sense that the young get up to all kinds of mischief. And there's a kind of sense that basically they should be allowed to, you know, let them sow their wild oats, but essentially they should get over it
是的。是的。而且没有这种概念，所以没有那种青年，我的意思是，“青年文化”这个词源于1942年，所以这是在强行回溯。但在罗马青少年中，没有那种我们称之为“青年文化”的东西，对吧？确实有一种感觉，即年轻人会惹出各种各样的麻烦。而且有一种观念基本上认为应该允许他们这样做，你知道，让他们去释放年少轻狂，但本质上他们应该克服这一点，
and then knock them down to more important things like conquering the Gauls or running for the consulship or something. So my sense would be, knowing nothing about it, that especially at the end of the Republic, that people are sort of bemoaning that the morals of the current generation are worse than, you know, sort of Cato figures.
然后把精力投入到更重要的事情上去，比如征服高卢、竞选执政官之类的事情。所以凭直觉，在对其一无所知的情况下，我认为尤其是在共和国末期，人们常常在哀叹当代道德比不上过去，你知道，就像加图那样的人物。
Was that a thing? Did Romans often sort of say, oh, everything's going to the dogs and young people today have no sense of standards and all the sort of standard things people say about teenagers? It's a running joke in comedies that you have the figure of the kind of the irascible, censorious daily mail reader. That's me. Yes.
真有这回事吗？罗马人经常会说，哦，世风日下，现在的年轻人没有丝毫标准，以及所有那些人们常用来评价青少年的标准说辞吗？在喜剧里这是一个贯穿始终的梗，里面总有那种暴躁、好为人师的《每日邮报》读者形象。那就是我。是的。
So Dominicus Sanbruchus. And then you have the kind of the young, extravagant Hellraiser. Tom Holland. Exactly. And this kind of does, this is a kind of political because in a sense, the divisions in Roman society are all kind of grounded in style.
所以就是“多米尼库斯·桑德布鲁库斯”（Dominicus Sanbruchus）。然后你就会有那种年轻、奢侈、纵情声色的享乐主义者形象。汤姆·霍兰德。没错。这在某种程度上确实具有政治色彩，因为从某种意义上说，罗马社会的内部分裂都植根于生活风格。
So the idea that you are a censorious, finger-wagging conservative is associated with age. And the idea that you're a kind of hell-raising guy who drives his zippy chariot with eight horses rather than with four is kind of associated with youth and in the imperial period this becomes a kind of crucial determinant as to whether you're a good or a bad emperor basically yeah so your caligulas and your nero's are kind of yes so we've got a question about i think about elegabalus who yes we do yes we do so from the splendidly named history of tammany hall podcast the modern idea some of the adolescent roman emperors elegabalus etc who i think became emperor when he was 14 seemed like the nightmare vision of giving a teen limitless power how were they viewed in ancient times as children or adult rulers like any other well basically the romans
所以，那种好为人师、指指点点的保守派形象是与年龄联系在一起的。而那种纵情声色、开着挂了八匹马拉的轻便战车而不是四匹马拉的车的享乐主义形象，则与青春联系在一起。在帝国时期，这成为决定你是一个好皇帝还是坏皇帝的关键因素，基本上是的。所以你的卡利古拉和尼禄就是……是的，所以我们有一个关于——我想是关于埃拉伽巴卢斯（Elagabalus）的问题，是的，我们有，是的，我们有。这个问题来自那个名字很酷的“坦慕尼协会历史”（History of Tammany Hall）播客：现代观念中，一些罗马少年皇帝，如埃拉伽巴卢斯等，我认为他14岁时就成了皇帝，这看起来就像是赋予青少年无限权力的一场噩梦般的幻象。在古代，他们是如何被看待的？是被当作孩子，还是像其他任何人一样的成年统治者？嗯，基本上罗马人
thought that that certainly in the republic that you should only have power if you had wrinkles. And in a way, what's most radical about the figure of Augustus, and everyone can conjure up an image of Augustus, is that he is portrayed as a kind of youthful, preternaturally youthful figure. And that is how he's portrayed right the way up till he dies. You know, he dies and he's very old. And that, again, is kind of drawing on the greek idea that youth is beautiful and associated with divinity so there's a kind of complex cultural nexus going on there but i don't think you have anything that corresponds to to a teenager a kind of protracted age that we would associate with with with those particular years i think that that is something much more recent and therefore i'm going to pass the ball on to you to how the teenager our idea of the teenager evolved i think it is a recent thing now
认为，至少在共和国时期，只有当你满脸皱纹时，你才应该拥有权力。从某种意义上说，屋大维这个人物最激进的地方在于——每个人脑海中都能浮现出屋大维的形象——他被描绘成一种具有超越常人的青春气息的形象。这就是他从年轻一直到死都被描绘的形象。你知道，他死的时候已经很老了。而这，再次借鉴了希腊人的观念，即青春是美丽的，并与神性相关联。所以那里存在着一种复杂的文化交织，但我认为并不存在任何对应于青少年的东西，没有那种我们与那些特定年华联系在一起的漫长时期。我认为这是一种近代得多的现象，因此我要把球传给你，让我们谈谈青少年的概念是如何演变的。我认为这确实是近代才有的事。
um there's a brilliant book on this by a guy called john savage who some writers some listeners will know as the guy who wrote the definitive book on punk and the sex pistols. And he has this book called Teenage, I think, The Creation or the Invention of Youth. And he starts in the late Victorian period. And I think what he's basically saying is, you know, in the late Victorian period, you have young people who we would now regard as adolescents who have spending money
现在，嗯，有一本关于这个主题的精彩著作，作者叫乔恩·萨维奇（Jon Savage），一些作家、一些听众可能会知道他，他写过关于朋克和性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols）的权威著作。他写了一本名为《青少年》（Teenage）的书，副标题我想是“青年的创造或发明”。他从维多利亚时代晚期开始讲起。我认为他的基本观点是，你知道，在维多利亚时代晚期，出现了一些年轻人，我们现在会把他们视为青少年，他们拥有零花钱，
and they can define themselves as different from their parents. And is it the spending money that's the key? I think it is the key. I mean, I think spending money is the key. Because, you know, you are 15. If you have no money, you have no ability to – it's very hard for you to create a culture of your own or to differentiate yourself from your parents or from – you know, you can't buy your own clothes.
并且他们能够将自己与父母区分开来。零花钱是关键吗？我认为这确实是关键。我的意思是，我认为零花钱是关键。因为，你知道，如果你15岁。如果你没有钱，你就没有能力——你很难创造属于你自己的文化，也很难把自己和父母区分开来，或者——你知道，你买不起自己的衣服。
You can't buy, you know, sort of cultural products, whether they are comics or books or records or whatever. But I think when you've got that spending money and this is, of course, the big age of consumerism, late Victorian America and Britain and France and so on, then then you can sort of forge this new identity. And in his book, he basically says there is a... His book is a sort of prehistory of the teenager. And he basically says there's about a 70-year period where people are sort of struggling to define what this person is, who's a girl or a boy between 13 and 18 or so. This is the age in which Baden-Powell is inventing the Boy Scouts.
你买不起，你知道，诸如漫画、书籍、唱片之类的文化产品。但我想当你有了零花钱——当然，这是消费主义的大时代，维多利亚时代晚期的美国、英国、法国等等——然后你就可以塑造这种新的身份。在他的书中，他基本上说存在一个……他的书是青少年史前史。他基本上说，大约有70年的时间，人们一直在努力给这种人下定义，也就是13岁到18岁左右的女孩或男孩。这也是贝登堡（Baden-Powell）发明童子军的时代。
And you have moral panics about people like Arthur Rimbaud, the French sort of teenage poet. And so there's a lot of stuff about teenagers, but they haven't really pinned down. People haven't decided on an agreed definition. And then it's really in the 1940s and it's in America. So the country where consumer culture is sort of most vibrant and most dynamic, that you have the invention of the teenage magazine.
人们对像阿蒂尔·兰波（Arthur Rimbaud，法国的少年诗人）这样的人物产生了道德恐慌。所以有很多关于青少年的讨论，但他们还没有真正确定下来。人们还没有就一个公认的定义达成一致。然后真正到了20世纪40年代，是在美国。所以，在消费文化最具活力、最蓬勃发展的国家，出现了青少年杂志的发明。
So 1944 is this big landmark year of a magazine called Seventeen, and it's the first real – And that's aimed at girls? It's aimed at girls. Because all the boys are away fighting the Japanese? They are, but I think throughout, right through into the 60s, 70s and so on, girls are absolutely, you know, they are central. They are the drivers of teenage culture.
所以1944年是一个重大的里程碑年份，出现了一本名为《十七岁》（Seventeen）的杂志，这是第一本真正的——那是针对女孩的吗？那是针对女孩的。因为所有的男孩都去跟日本人打仗了吗？他们是的，但我认为自始至终，一直到60年代、70年代等等，女孩绝对是，你知道，她们是核心。她们是青少年文化的驱动力。
Because they're spending more or why? Because, yeah, I think because they have, girls often have sort of part-time jobs. But also girls, you know, Beatlemania is all about girls. I think because girls often have sort of part-time jobs. But also girls, you know, Beatlemania is all about girls. So Beatlemania in the 60s is driven by girls. And girls, you know, it's boy bands rather than girl bands that drive pop and rock music. You know, the Beatles, the Stones, the Who and so on.
因为她们花钱更多，还是为什么？因为，是的，我想是因为女孩通常有某种兼职工作。而且女孩，你知道，“披头士狂热”完全是关于女孩的。我想因为女孩通常有某种兼职工作。而且女孩，你知道，“披头士狂热”全是由女孩推动的。所以在60年代，“披头士狂热”是由女孩驱动的。并且女孩，你知道，推动流行和摇滚音乐的是男孩乐队，而不是女孩乐队。你知道，披头士乐队、滚石乐队、“谁人”乐队等等。
Often their audience isn't always girls, but girls are the most loyal part of the audience and girls spend more on clothes they spend more on dance hall tickets they spend more on magazines on makeup so there's a whole kind of cosmetics part of that market the boys don't enter into at all um so girls are the big drivers and girls magazines sell more than boys magazines do so i think girls drove the whole thing from the 1940s for the next 30 or 40 years. Can I just go back to the prehistory of that in the 19th century?
通常他们的观众并不全是女孩，但女孩是观众中最忠实的部分，女孩在衣服上花更多的钱，在舞厅门票上花更多的钱，在杂志、化妆品上花更多的钱，所以那个市场中存在着一整块化妆品消费，男孩根本不涉足这方面。所以女孩是主要的推动力，女孩杂志的销量也超过男孩杂志。所以我认为从20世纪40年代开始，在接下来的三四十年里，女孩推动了整个事情的发展。我能回到19世纪那段前史吗？
Yeah. Because in the 19th century and indeed in the 20th century, there is a living link with the ancient world in the form of boarding schools. Yes. Which are consciously modelled in the form of boarding schools yes yeah which are consciously modeled on the kind of the spartan ideal that you have to take kind of young people and treat them like like animals to be broken in and remolded and reshaped yeah and so dr arnold yeah so so that's that's that's a kind of Victorian thing.
可以。因为在19世纪甚至20世纪，寄宿学校的形式构成了与古代世界的活生生的联系。是的。它们是有意识地以寄宿学校的形式为蓝本——是的，是的，它们是有意识地模仿斯巴达的理想，即你必须带走年轻人，像驯服动物一样对待他们，去打破他们、重塑他们。是的，所以阿诺德博士（Dr. Arnold）——所以，所以那是一种维多利亚时代的现象。
And that, I mean, I guess that kind of is providing a model for the boy scouts, isn't it? And the girl guides, the idea that, you know, otherwise they'll all just run wild. And also, doesn't it also feed into the Hitler youth? I think, well, I think the Hitler youth. So if you sort of take the Hitler Youth as an endpoint, as what we would now see as a sort of uniquely sinister endpoint, the Hitler Youth makes sense to people
而这，我的意思是，我想这为童子军提供了一种模式，对吧？还有女童子军，那种观念认为，否则他们都会野蛮生长。而且，这难道没有融入到希特勒青年团（Hitler Youth）中吗？我认为，好吧，我认为希特勒青年团。如果你把希特勒青年团当作终点，当作我们现在所看到的一种极其邪恶的终点，那么希特勒青年团在
in the 1930s in a way that it doesn't to us today because they live in an age where people have always been part of youth groups. Uniforms. And they've all often worn uniforms and the uniform is not seen as sinister.
20世纪30年代的人看来是合情合理的，而这在我们今天的眼里则不然，因为他们生活在这样一个时代：人们一直都是青年组织的一部分。制服。而且他们通常都穿着制服，制服并不被视为邪恶的象征。
So the Boy Scouts is exactly right as a kind of, it's not exactly a model, but it's part of the same constellation. I mean, there's all these, in Germany in particular, they love all these stuff about sort of strange rambling groups where they go and commune with nature
所以童军运动作为一个种类来说完全是正确的，虽然它不完全是一个模范，但它属于同一个星系。我的意思是，有很多这样的组织，特别是在德国，他们非常喜欢所有这些关于那种奇怪的徒步漫游团体的玩意儿，他们去那里与自然交流
and all this sort of stuff. They're very romantic. I mean, they're very idealistic. And you're right, I think as well, that the public schools before that, this idea of the public school spirit and play up, play play up and play the game i mean i love all this stuff actually but but all that sort of dr arnold tom brown school does oh i really i you know that poem the henry newbolt poem yes um the hush and the close shoulder smooth yeah i love i love that
诸如此类的东西。它们非常浪漫。我的意思是，它们非常理想主义。而且你说得对，我认为之前的公立学校也是如此，这种公立学校精神以及“努力吧，努力吧，在比赛中好好表现”的理念——其实我挺喜欢这些东西的——但所有那种阿诺德博士、汤姆·布朗式的学校，哦，我真的，你知道亨利·纽博尔特的诗吗？是的，呃，“当寂静笼罩着闭合的草坪”……是的，我爱，我爱那个
i love that i've been i've been reading that to my son since he was about two, with a tear in my, a manly tear in my eye. And have you succeeded in shaping him into, molding him into a... I think so, yeah. I think so. That'd be an interesting experiment. I mean, we're probably the only household in Britain where Billy Bunter features as a regular bedtime story.
我爱那个，我从我儿子大约两岁起就一直在给他读那首诗，眼里含着泪水，男人的眼泪。你成功把他塑造成、塑造成为一个……我想是的，是的。我想是的。那将是一个有趣的实验。我的意思是，我们可能是英国唯一一个把《比利·班特》作为常规睡前故事的家庭了。
So Billy Bunter, that's... Yeah. So he appears in a comic, doesn't he? The Magnet. I'm obsessed with Billy Bunter. I'm so glad we've gone into billy bunter i didn't see this coming at all but but that's a bit earlier is it or is that about 19 no no i mean but that's targeted at at what what kind of age group i would say about probably from about 10 to about 15 or 16 i I would have said. So very unexpected people. Those are by far the most influential stories. Or well-loved, but people like Aneurin Bevan.
所以《比利·班特》，那是……对。所以他出现在一本漫画里，对吧？《磁石》杂志。我迷上了《比利·班特》。我很高兴我们聊到了比利·班特，我一点也没预料到这一点，但这稍微早一点吗？还是大约在19……不，不，我的意思是，那是针对什么、什么年龄段的？我会说大概是从10岁左右到15岁或16岁左右吧。所以是非常意想不到的人。这些是迄今为止最具影响力的故事。或者深受欢迎的故事，像安奈林·贝文这样的人。
Aneurin Bevan, the Labour firebrand, founder of the NHS, he was banned from his father from reading magnets, sort of boys' stories, Billy Bunter stories. And he hid them, I think, under a railway bridge. And why was he banned? Because they were seen as not improving, not, you know, they weren't serious. But lots of, if you read the memoirs
安奈林·贝文，工党的激进分子、NHS的创始人，他曾被父亲禁止阅读《磁石》杂志，也就是那种男孩的故事、比利·班特的故事。我想他把它们藏在了一座铁路桥下。为什么他被禁呢？因为它们被视为没有营养，没有……你知道的，它们不够严肃。但是，如果你读过许多回忆录
of working class boys, boys particularly in Britain, in the first half of the 20th century, tons of them will say they learned about life from the Billy Bunter stories. They learned about what it was to be a man. They learned about pluck, didn't they? Pluck. Pluck is the word.
工人阶级男孩的，特别是英国男孩在20世纪上半叶的回忆录，成千上万的人会说他们从比利·班特的故事中了解了生活。他们了解了什么是男子汉。他们学会了勇气，对吧？勇气。勇气就是这个词。
Collective spirit, about teamwork. And they would say that their idol was this guy who's the captain of the remove, Harry Wharton, who's this sort of incredibly noble, brave, hardworking, dutiful figure. You know, the kind of man who, he sort of enforces discipline among the other boys. He's chivalrous. You know, he'd always help a girl in distress. He's always fighting off footpads
集体精神，团队合作。他们会说他们的偶像就是这个家伙，也就是“升班”班长哈里·沃顿，他是一个极其高尚、勇敢、努力、有责任感的形象。你知道的，那种在其他男孩中强制执行纪律的男人。他是骑士风度的。你知道的，他总是会帮助陷入困境的女孩。他总是在与那些小偷
and members of the working classes who were trying to invade Greyfriars. Amazing that Niren Bevan was into this. Well, of course, the people who are the baddies are sort of ruffians. They're footpads who are always trying to get in and molest the boys or steal precious stamps. But this is in a private school.
以及试图侵入格雷弗里尔斯的工人阶级成员搏斗。令人惊奇的是，奈林·贝文竟然迷恋这个。嗯，当然，那些坏人都是些暴徒。他们是那些总是试图进来骚扰男孩或偷窃珍贵邮票的小偷。但这是一所私立学校。
Yeah, it is. So it just seems an odd thing for the stalwart of the Labour Party. But they were colossally popular among working-class children. So there's a book called – what's it called? Jonathan Rose? I can't remember. The Intellectual Life of the English Working Classes, I think it's called. And it talks a lot about these boys' stories and how much they...
是的，确实是。所以对于工党的中流砥柱来说，这似乎是一件很奇怪的事情。但它们在工人阶级儿童中非常受欢迎。所以有一本书叫——它叫什么来着？乔纳森·罗斯？我不记得了。我想书名叫《英国工人阶级的知识生活》。它大量谈到了这些男孩的故事以及它们对他们有多大影响……
Because the people who consume them are not other private schoolboys, by and large. I think they are people outside that world. Just like most Harry Potter readers don't go to boarding school. Okay, okay. So in Britain, and perhaps in Germany as well, perhaps less so in America, this sense that the role models, it's conformist, it's collectivist, it's everything that today we tend not to associate with teenagers. I think teenagers are terribly conformist.
因为消费它们的人大体上并不是其他私立学校的男孩。我认为他们是那个世界之外的人。就像大多数《哈利·波特》的读者并不去寄宿学校一样。好的，好的。所以在英国，或许在德国也是如此，在美国可能少一些，这种感觉是，榜样是顺从的、集体主义的，它具备了一切我们今天往往不与青少年联系在一起的特质。我认为青少年是非常顺从的。
Okay, they are. They are, but they're conformist in the sense that they don't want to be conformist. They're not all kind of saying, oh, please, can I dress up in uniforms? I mean, I know that they are kind of creating uniforms because, you know, mods and rockers and punks and New Wave. I mean, I know that. But you know what I mean?
好吧，他们是的。他们是的，但他们的顺从在于他们不想显得顺从。他们并不是都在那种说，“哦，求求你，我能穿上制服吗？”我的意思是，我知道他们某种程度上在创造制服，因为，你知道的，摩斯族、摇滚族、朋克族和新浪潮。我的意思是，我知道这一点。但你知道我的意思吗？
There's quite a gear shift there. I mean, the John Savage book, which you mentioned, does have this amazing thing about the German youth who were not joining the youth with any great enthusiasm, who were kind of listening to swing bands and to English music in Hamburg. Yeah, it's incredible. It's like a Beatles prehistory. 20 years before the Beatles went and played at the Rieke Bar. It's such a great thing, isn't it, Tom? Because you don't think, I mean, before I read that book,
那里有一个很大的档位切换。我的意思是，你提到的约翰·萨维奇的书，确实有一个关于德国青年的惊人内容，他们并没有以极大的热情加入青年团，而是在汉堡听摇摆乐队和英国音乐。是的，这太不可思议了。这就像是披头士乐队的前传。在披头士去里卡酒吧演出20年之前。汤姆，这真是一件很棒的事，对吧？因为你不会想到，在我读那本书之前，
it had never occurred to me that the Third Reich would have this vibrant oppositional youth culture. Yeah, youth scene. And that they were all obsessed with English music. Yeah, it's great. That has parallels elsewhere in Europe. So again, something that I hadn't really thought of, I remember reading Kingsley Amis' memoirs.
我从未想过第三帝国会有如此充满活力的对立青年文化。是的，青年亚文化。而且他们都痴迷于英国音乐。是的，太棒了。这在欧洲其他地方也有相似之处。所以同样地，我之前没有真正想到这一点，我记得读过金斯利·阿米斯的自传。
And Kingsley Amis, who's a novelist, who you think of as this utter reactionary buffer. He talks about how he's in the 1930s in South London or wherever he is. He's having these terrible rows with his dad about jazz. So he thinks jazz, now we think of jazz as a very tweedy and sort of old-fashioned. But at the time, jazz has just come from America.
金斯利·阿米斯是一位小说家，你可能会认为他是一个彻头彻尾的反动老顽固。他谈到他在20世纪30年代的伦敦南部或其他什么地方。他正为爵士乐与他父亲发生激烈的争吵。所以他认为爵士乐——现在我们认为爵士乐非常古板且过时。但在当时，爵士乐刚刚从美国传入。
So Kingsley Amis' dad has turned that awful racket down. He is. That's exactly what's happening. He's saying, what is wrong with you, boy? Take a cold shower and stop. That's not music. Yeah, stop. And Kingsley was just like, oh, no, this is the really cool music of the day.
所以金斯利·阿米斯的父亲把那个可怕的噪音关小了。他就是这样。这正是发生的事情。他说，你这孩子怎么了？洗个冷水澡，然后停下来。那不是音乐。是的，停下。而金斯利则是一副“哦，不，这是当今真正酷的音乐”的态度。
So I think in the 30s, which we now tend to caricature as all flat caps and kind of george orwell i think in the 30s you do have a teenage culture across the kind of industrialized world and it's to do with music because you've obviously got record players so already you know we have that sort of sense of of a sort of youth culture emerging so you've got the word youth culture and the word teenager both really being coined in 1944 and then obviously when the economy takes off at the end of the second world war that all just completely explodes okay but dominic i think that's enough of the of the prehistory for teenagers so you've set it up nicely uh i think we should have a break now and then when we come back we should um we should have
所以我认为在30年代，我们现在倾向于将其刻板印象化为满大街的平顶帽和乔治·奥威尔式的氛围，我认为在30年代，整个工业化世界确实存在着一种青少年文化，这与音乐有关，因为你显然有了唱盘，所以，你知道的，我们已经有了这种正在萌芽的青年文化的感觉——所以“青年文化”和“青少年”这两个词真正都是在1944年被造出来的，然后很明显，当经济在第二次世界大战结束时腾飞时，这一切就彻底爆发了。好吧，不过多米尼克，我认为关于青少年的前史已经够了——所以你把它铺垫得很好，呃，我想我们现在该休息一下了，然后当我们回来时，我们应该呃，我们应该
a look at the way that the notion of the teenager has evolved since the second world war so um let's do a very teenagery thing and go to a commercial break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back.
来看看自二战以来“青少年”这一概念是如何演变的——所以，让我们做一个非常符合青少年风格的事情，进一段商业广告吧。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺界八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的幕后大幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想免广告收听、获取独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回来。
We are giving you, I hope, some teenage kicks. And we've been looking at the deep prehistory of the teenager, and then the prehistory of the teenager. And we've now arrived, well, at the 40s, and we're into the 50s, looking at the way that the concept of teenage culture evolves. And Dominic, question here for you from Alex, I think it's Shiphorst. Was James Dean the first teenager? Would that have been recognised back in the 50s or has time given us that impression? So James Dean is the kind, you know, leather jacket. Yeah. Hair greased up.
我希望我们正在为你带来一些“青少年狂热”。我们一直在研究青少年的深层前史，然后是青少年的前史，现在我们来到了——嗯，40年代，并进入了50年代，探讨青年文化概念演变的方式。多米尼克，这里有一个亚历克斯（我想他叫希普霍斯特）给你的问题。詹姆斯·迪恩是第一个青少年吗？这在50年代会被人认可，还是时间给了我们这种印象？所以詹姆斯·迪恩就是那种，你知道的，皮夹克。是的。头发抹了油。
Curled lip. Yeah, surly, racing cars to the edge of cliffs, all that kind of, we've all done it. Is he the first? No, he's not the first um but i suppose yeah because the there is no first teenager but the certainly by the end of the 1940s the concept of the teenager is very well established but i think what james dean probably is is he's part of a sort of i don't know is it a triumvirate or or you got um Sinatra? It's more than a triumvirate. Frank Sinatra, Marlon Brando,
撇着嘴。是的，阴郁，开着赛车冲向悬崖边缘，所有这些——我们都曾做过。他是第一个吗？不，他不是第一个，呃，不过我想是的，因为并没有“第一个青少年”，但在20世纪40年代末之前，青少年的概念就已经非常成熟了，但我认为詹姆斯·迪恩可能扮演的角色是，他是某种——我不知道，是一个三人组合的一部分吗？或者你有，呃，弗兰克·辛纳屈？这超出了三人组合的范畴。弗兰克·辛纳屈、马龙·白兰度，
then there was Presley, the biggest one of all. People who define the teenage boy or the teenage young man. I mean, Frank Sinatra is actually much older, but they are rebellious. They are glamorous. They are different from their parents and different from their elders. And that's obviously an American archetype and then it's taken up
然后是普雷斯利，其中最大的一个。定义了少年男子或年轻男子的那些人。我的意思是，弗兰克·辛纳屈实际上要年长得多，但他们是叛逆的。他们光芒四射。他们与父母不同，与长辈不同。这显然是一个美国原型，然后它被
in the rest of Western Europe. And Frank Sinatra is not drafted in the Second World War, is he? Is that right? I didn't know. I know nothing about Frank Sinatra. Yeah, so I think he's playing, he's kind of doing gigs. I know he's, yeah, he's very, that's his breakthrough is the early
西欧其他地方所采纳。弗兰克·辛纳屈在二战期间没有被征兵，对吧？是这样吗？我不知道。我对弗兰克·辛纳屈一无所知。是的，所以我想他当时在演出，他在做一些巡演。我知道他，是的，他非常——那是他的突破期是在早期
1940s. But he's in his 20s then already, but he's appealing to this new – he is the big star who appeals to this new – So this is proto-Beatlemania. This is the girls kind of – And basically, so girls in the 40s, they're at home. Yeah. Boys are away.
40年代。但他当时已经20多岁了，但他吸引了这种新兴的——他就是吸引这种新兴群体的超级巨星——所以这就是披头士狂热的前身。这就是女孩们那种——基本上，40年代的女孩们待在家里的。是的。男孩们都不在。
They're posters of Frank Sinatra. Yeah. And so presumably it's not a coincidence that this is when the word teenager starts to be marketed well i think you've also got america's been through the depression so the second world war restarts the engines of american capitalism and that's why the word teenager is invented because all these girls who are working because as you say that the boys are away so young women are flooding into the workforce they have money and people i always think of youth culture and teenage culture it's a colossal enterprise and separating young people from their money you know it's not about i i never think it's about idealism or romanticism i think
到处都是弗兰克·辛纳屈的海报。是的。所以这大概不是巧合，正是在这个时候，“青少年”这个词开始被市场化。嗯，我认为美国也经历了经济大萧条，所以第二次世界大战重启了美国资本主义的发动机，这就是为什么“青少年”这个词被发明出来，因为所有这些正在工作的女孩们——正如你所说，男孩们都不在家，所以年轻女性大量涌入劳动力市场，她们有钱，而且人们——我总是认为青年文化和青少年文化是一项庞大的商业运作，把年轻人和他们的钱分离开来（你知道的，这无关理想主义或浪漫主义，我认为
it's just a massive marketing exercise and one of the most successful marketing exercises in history. And do you think that... So when do people we now call teenagers start to identify themselves as teenagers? What comes first, the marketing or the sense of identity? Oh, I think there was a sense of identity already. So you had gangs. You had tribes and gangs before the Second World War. But I think the point at which people refer to themselves as teenagers
它只是一次巨大的市场营销活动，也是历史上最成功的市场营销活动之一。你认为……那么，我们现在称为青少年的群体从什么时候开始把自己认同为青少年的？是市场营销先行，还是身份认同感先行？哦，我认为认同感已经存在了。所以在二战之前，你就有帮派了。你就有部落和帮派。但我认为人们开始自称为青少年的时刻
probably comes in the 1950s. And certainly, you become a teenager in 1956 or 1957, you think of yourself as a teenager, and you use the word very unselfconsciously. So we've got a question from Matthew Butcher. You mentioned gangs. Yeah. Was the moral panic in the 50s about teenagers both true and the first time this had been perceived so that's that is that is a a kind of running theme isn't it that the moment you have teenagers you have adults who are worrying about teenagers yeah and they're generally seen
大概出现在20世纪50年代。当然，如果你在1956年或1957年成为一名青少年，你会认为自己是一个青少年，并且会非常自然地使用这个词。所以我们有一个来自马修·布彻的问题。你提到了帮派。是的。50年代关于青少年的道德恐慌既是真实的，又是人们第一次意识到这种现象吗？所以——这是一个贯穿始终的主题，对吧？只要你有了青少年，你就会有为青少年担心的成年人。是的，他们通常被看作
as kind of bad but you sort of said didn't you, that the people in the ancient world were worried about the young, they thought the young were unreliable. So I think that has run, it's my sense is that that has run through history. But I think, I think, I think it's different because in the ancient world, there's assumption that the younger are just by nature problematic and
是某种坏孩子，但你之前不是说过吗，古代世界的人也担心年轻人，他们认为年轻人不可靠。所以我觉得这贯穿了历史，我的感觉是这贯穿了整个历史。但我认为，我认为，我认为情况有所不同，因为在古代世界，人们认为年轻人天生就是有问题的，而且
right. Yeah. Kind of irresponsible. Whereas I think what's distinctive, certainly since the war, maybe even before that, is that this is a generational thing. And I guess that for people in the 50s and 60s, it's particularly bruising because they feel that they've never seen anything like this before that suddenly, particularly in the 60s, I would guess.
对。是的。某种程度上不负责任。然而我认为自战争以来（或许在此之前也是如此）与众不同之处在于，这是一种代际现象。我想对于50年代和60年代的人来说，这尤为让人感到打击，因为他们觉得他们从未见过这样的事——突然之间，特别是在60年代，我猜。
I think that's right. I think you do see it in the 50s, actually, Tom. And I think you first see it. It's not really a moral generation gap, but there's an article by Keith Waterhouse in the late 1950s in one of the British papers. And it says, you know, our children are changing. And it has all this stuff about they're bigger, they're taller, they reach puberty earlier, all of which is true because their health is better and their diet is better.
我认为是的。汤姆，实际上你确实在50年代就能看到这一点。我认为你首先能看到它。这并不完全是一场道德上的代沟，但在20世纪50年代末，英国某家报纸上发表了一篇文章，作者是基斯·沃特豪斯。上面写着，你知道的，我们的孩子们正在改变。其中讲到他们体型更大、个子更高、进入青春期更早，所有这些都是事实，因为他们的健康状况更好、饮食更好。
So young people are becoming mature much more quickly. They're much more self-confident. They're bigger. They're more sexually active. They have more money. They're more visible. They're kind of louder. And so that's when you start to get a lot of the sort of moral panic stuff.
所以年轻人成熟得快得多。他们更加自信。他们体型更大。他们的性活跃度更高。他们更有钱。他们的存在感更强。他们某种程度上更大胆。所以这就是你开始看到大量类似道德恐慌现象的时候。
And because there's always this sort of sense among when people talk about history that sort of poverty is a source of great anxiety and affluence is to be celebrated but often affluence creates terrible anxieties of its own and that's definitely what happened in the 50s and 60s so teenagers with money buying shirts and buying magazines and records was profoundly unsettling to a lot of the elders. They kind of thought, you know, what are they doing? They're wasting money on rubbish and they don't listen to us. And they've got all this sort of, they're more articulate and they're confident and they're having sex with each other and they're playing their loud music
而且因为人们在谈论历史时总是有一种感觉，即贫穷是巨大焦虑的来源，而富裕应当受到赞美，但通常富裕本身也会产生可怕的焦虑，这绝对是50年代和60年代发生的事情。因此，有钱的青少年购买衬衫、杂志和唱片，这让许多长辈深感不安。他们某种程度上会想，你知道，他们在干什么？他们在把钱浪费在垃圾上，而且他们不听我们的。他们拥有所有这些——他们口才更好、更自信、彼此发生性关系、播放他们的吵闹音乐
and all this sort of stuff. And, you know, that's a huge part of the sort of social and cultural story of, let's say, Britain or America in the 50s and 60s. So there's that famous comment by John Lennon that I think John Savage quotes. And he's talking about America and says that we always look to America because they had teenagers and nowhere else did. Yeah. Well, they had teenagers because they weren't going through austerity. Right. So in Britain, and I guess Europe, the emergence of the teenager is also a repudiation of the, I mean, not just of austerity, but what had been cast as the virtues necessary to win a war.
诸如此类的东西。你知道，这构成了50年代和60年代英国或美国社会和文化故事的很大一部分。所以约翰·列农有过那句著名的评论，我想约翰·萨维奇引用过。他在谈到美国时说，我们总是仰望美国，因为他们有青少年，而其他地方都没有。是的。嗯，他们有青少年是因为他们没有经历紧缩政策。所以，在英国以及我猜在欧洲，青少年的出现也是对——我的意思是，不仅仅是对紧缩政策的否定，也是对那些曾被视为赢得战争所必需的美德的否定。
Yeah, Spartan virtues. Spartan virtues. Absolutely. And they become objects of mockery on the part of kind of cutting edge teenagers. I know that you will say that this was a minority pursuit and that probably in the 60s, most teenagers were cutting their hair and joining the cadet corps or something.
是的，斯巴达式美德。斯巴达式美德。绝对是的。它们成了走在时代前沿的青少年的嘲笑对象。我知道你会说这只是少数人的追求，可能在60年代，大多数青少年都在剪头发并加入学员预备役军团之类的。
Just think about it. If you're a teenager in 1965, Tom, I mean, somebody starts up about the war again. I mean, you're kind of rolling your eyes and you're sick of, you know, shut up, grandad. You know, you live with the legacy of it, but it's incredibly boring and tiresome to be told about it. So I think actually even teenagers who weren't rebellious, and you're sick of, you know, shut up, grandad. You know, you live with the legacy of it, but it's incredibly boring and tiresome to be told about it.
试想一下。1965年的一个青少年，汤姆，我是说，如果有人又开始谈论战争。我的意思是，你大概会翻个白眼，然后觉得厌烦，你知道的，闭嘴吧，爷爷。你知道的，你生活在它的历史遗留影响中，但听别人唠叨这些简直无聊透顶、令人厌烦。所以我觉得实际上，即使是那些并不叛逆的青少年，你知道的，闭嘴吧，爷爷。你知道的，你生活在它的历史遗留影响中，但听别人唠叨这些简直无聊透顶、令人厌烦。
So I think actually even teenagers who weren't rebellious, i.e. most teenagers, because they weren't, would probably have, you know, they were sick of being lectured about, oh, this was the spirit of Dunkirk and all that. They were much more resistant to that actually then, I think, than people are now because it was, you know, it was their parents who were lecturing them about it the um the classic um illustration of that is if yeah the malcolm mcdowell film is set in spectacularly brutal public school where everyone has to be kind of trained to go out and join the army or run the british empire right and
所以我觉得实际上，即使是那些并不叛逆的青少年，也就是大多数青少年，因为他们本就不叛逆，大概也会对被说教感到厌烦，哦，这就是敦刻尔克精神之类的话题。实际上，他们当时对此的抵触情绪，我觉得要比现在的人更强，因为那是，你知道的，那是他们的父母在对他们说教。这方面一个经典的例子，就是那个马尔科姆·麦克道威尔主演的电影，背景是一所极其残暴的公立学校，每个人都被训练着去参军或者统治大英帝国，对吧？
that's i think it's 68 is it 68 it's's Lindy Anderson. And he goes back to his old school, Cheltenham, and he doesn't tell them what he's doing. I mean, that's the thing. He gets permission because it's his old school. And he sort of says, I want to come and do this film about that school. Okay. So how much, for those who haven't seen it, it's about three rebellious boys.
那是，我觉得是68年吧？68年，导演是林德·安德森。他回到了他的母校切尔滕纳姆，而且他没有告诉他们他在做什么。我的意思是，事情就是这样。他获得了许可，因为那是他的母校。他有点像是说，我想来拍一部关于那所学校的电影。好的。那么，对于没看过这部电影的人来说，它讲述了三个叛逆男孩的故事。
And there's somebody in the film called The Girl. Yes. He wouldn't do that now. And it ends... Am I giving a spoiler? No, I mean, you can give it away. Yeah, that it ends up with them kind of machine gunning everybody on speech day.
电影里有一个角色叫“女孩”。是的。他现在可不会这么拍了。结局是……我在剧透吗？不，我的意思是，你可以剧透。是的，结局是他们在演讲日用机枪扫射了所有人。
And that's the ultimate sort of generation gap film, I think, isn't it, really? Yes, I think so. It comes at that moment in the late 60s when all the talk is of the generation gap, which I think is actually a bit exaggerated. So i don't think there is a colossal chip but then what you get at the end of the 70s is new generation of teenagers turning on the previous generation of teenagers yeah so that's the kind of the essence of punk is to well actually you know what
这可以说是终极的代沟电影，对吧？是的，我想是的。它诞生于60年代末那个满嘴都是代沟的时期，而我觉得代沟其实被夸大了。所以我并不认为有什么深仇大恨。但随后你在70年代末看到的，是一代新的青少年开始反戈前一代青少年，对吧？所以朋克的核心就是——其实，你知道吗？
i you're right about that but i thought you were going to say something completely different which is i'm going to say that in 1979 first time voters so people who are 18 19 20 21 they're one of the biggest swing groups to margaret thatcher and the conservatives which is it which is which if you were saying that it would have been right because that is a repudiation of their 60s predecessors. But you're right, punk is also part of that. So punk is a repudiation of what's gone before. So then you start to get, I suppose,
关于这一点你说得对，但我以为你要说的是完全不同的事情，我要说的是，在1979年，首次投票的选民，也就是18、19、20、21岁的人，他们是转向玛格丽特·撒切尔和保守党的最庞大的摇摆群体之一。如果你刚才说的是这个，那就对了，因为那是对他们60年代前辈的一种唾弃。不过你说得对，朋克也是其中的一部分。所以朋克是对过去事物的一种唾弃。那么接着你会开始看到，我想，
now you're into the second generation of kind of classic teen, or third generation. And the really interesting thing then is that being a teenager is not just about repudiating mum and dad. It's about repudiating the earlier generation. Okay, so there's a question here from Andy May, who asks, looking from the perspective of 2021, obviously, why have those teenage tribes died out now?
现在你进入了第二代经典的青少年，或者说第三代。然后真正有趣的是，作为一个青少年，不仅仅是为了跟爸爸妈妈唱反调。它更是为了反抗更早的那一代人。好的，这里有一个来自安迪·梅的问题，他问，从2021年的视角来看，很显然，为什么那些青少年的亚文化群体现在都消亡了？
Will there be new ones in the future? Mods, by a million miles, they have the music and the style. So Mods v. Rockers is the classic. That won't mean anything probably to our non-British listeners. But in Britain, Mods v. Rockers is the classic clash, isn't it? Because it's about class. and then once you've had the teenage rebellion against the previous generation of teenagers, where do you have to go? I mean, in a way, and in a way, I guess the implication is that adults have kind of remained teenage. That's the big change, isn't it? That's the big change, isn't it? That's the big change. So it's very difficult now for teenagers to rebel
未来还会出现新的亚文化群体吗？摩斯族（Mods），毫无悬念，他们拥有音乐和风格。所以摩斯族对摇克族（Rockers）是经典的对抗。这对我们的非英国听众来说可能没有什么意义。但在英国，摩斯族对摇克族是经典的冲突，不是吗？因为这关乎阶级。然后，一旦你经历了青少年对上一代青少年的叛逆，你还能去哪里呢？我的意思是，从某种程度上说，某种程度上，我的暗示是成年人某种程度上一直保持着青少年的心态。这才是巨大的改变，对吧？这才是巨大的改变，对吧？这才是巨大的改变。所以现在青少年很难去反叛了，
in the way that a teenager in the 60s rebelled. I think that's a profound change. Imagine when we were teenagers. See, when I was a teenager in late 80s, early 90s, the thought that my dad might share interests with me would have been utterly unthinkable. Whereas now, you know, I share interests with my son who been utterly unthinkable. Whereas now, you know, I share interests with my son who isn't even a teenager yet.
就像60年代的青少年那样去反叛。我认为这是一个深刻的变化。想象一下我们当青少年的时期。你看，当我在80年代末90年代初当青少年时，我爸可能会跟我有共同兴趣这种想法简直是不可想象的。然而现在，你知道的，我和我儿子有共同的兴趣，而他甚至还不是个青少年。然而现在，你知道的，我和我儿子有共同的兴趣，而他甚至还不是个青少年。
No, but you're raising him on Kipling. So there's every prospect that he will be the sole teenager in 2020s Britain, able actually to rebel against his father. Yeah, what a terrifying prospect that will never happen. Run off and start reading The Guardian. That will never happen. He knows better than to do that sort of that sort of i can't
不，但你是用吉卜林的作品来培养他的。所以很有可能他会成为2020年代英国唯一一个真正能够反叛他父亲的青少年。是的，这是一个多么可怕的前景，这种情况永远不会发生。跑去看《卫报》吧。那绝不可能发生。他很懂事，不会去做那种……那种……我等
wait i can't wait but um no you're right i think it's much harder also culture is generally so fragmented now that there are fewer tribes i mean those tribes do exist and some of our listeners may well sort of tweet us and say oh oh, you're forgetting these people or those people. But actually, I think there are far, you know, that sort of ecosystem. So in Britain, that ecosystem, I mean, something like Top of the Pops plays such a colossal part in sort of defining what people listen to, but also how they looked. And that has gone, hasn't it? It's so fragmented. You don't think that that's just because you know we're two middle-aged men um and we can't see what they see we can't i mean isn't tiktok and i don't know
不及了，我等不及了。但是，不，你说得对，我认为现在要困难得多，而且文化总体上也变得如此碎片化，以至于亚文化群体越来越少了。我的意思是，这些亚文化群体确实存在，我们的一些听众很可能会在推特上留言说，哦，哦，你们漏掉了这群人或那群人。但实际上，我认为你们远——你知道的，那种生态系统。所以在英国，那种生态系统，我的意思是，像《流行音乐排行榜》（Top of the Pops）这样的节目在很大程度上定义了人们听什么音乐，以及他们的穿着打扮。而这一切都消失了，不是吗？它太碎片化了。难道你不认为这只是因为你知道我们是两个中年男人，
but that does create things that does create a common language and a common culture but don't forget if you ted had talked to the mods and the rockers or later on punks or new romantics i mean these were so mainstream that middle-aged men would have been aware of them. So in other words, they would have been featured. They were, you know, the Daily Mirror or The Sun would publish sort of double page spreads with a guide to the latest, you know, what are your kids wearing?
我们看不到他们所看到的，我们不能——我的意思是，难道TikTok和——我不知道，但这确实创造了一些东西，它创造了一种共同的语言和共同的文化。但别忘了，如果你跟摩斯族和摇克族交谈，或者后来的朋克族或新浪漫主义者，我的意思是，这些文化是如此主流，以至于中年男人都会知道它们。换句话说，它们会被报道。它们是，你知道的，《每日镜报》或《太阳报》会发表双跨页报道，并附有一份指南，介绍最新的——你的孩子们都在穿什么？
And why it's bad. They really did do this sort of stuff. I mean, this was, they would have, it was part of mainstream culture in a way that I don't think And so teenage life is a lot more boring as a result because we're not playing our role. We're not getting indignant about it. Well, here's Joey McCarthy's question.
以及为什么这样不好。他们真的会做这种事情。我的意思是，这是，它们曾是主流文化的一部分，而我不认为现在还是这样。因此，青少年的生活因此变得更加无聊，因为我们没有扮演好我们的角色。我们没有对此感到义愤填膺。好吧，这里是乔伊·麦卡锡的问题。
I don't know if it's the same Joey McCarthy. I think it is. An associate of this podcast. Our producer, yes. And he says, whatever happened to teenage rebellion, drug use, teenage pregnancy and youth all reduced massively in the past decade. Now, you're
我不知道这是否是同一个乔伊·麦卡锡。我想是的。本播客的同仁。我们的制作人，是的。他说，青少年叛逆、吸毒、青少年怀孕和青少年犯罪到底怎么了，在过去十年里都大幅减少了。现在，你是
the father of one ex-teenager and one still a teenager i think one still a teenager yeah so you must know all about this what has happened why have they why are they all so conservative if they are so conservative um i feel that this is rapidly mutating into a kind of parent daughter podcast of the kind that i'm not really sure what to say to that. I don't know. I mean, I think that there's always the risk of extrapolating from the personal to the... Certainly, there are deep streaks of rebellion.
一个前青少年的父亲和一个仍然是青少年的父亲——我觉得还有一个是青少年，对吧？所以你一定对这一切了如指掌，到底发生了什么？为什么他们都这么保守，如果他们真的很保守的话。我感觉这正在迅速演变成一种父母与女儿们的播客，让我有点不知道该说些什么好。我不知道。我的意思是，我觉得总是存在从个人推断到……的风险。当然，其中有着深深的叛逆倾向。
And I would say one that's kind of hit just at the moment is veganism has hit our fridge. So that's kind of annoying, but one that obviously we have to be supportive about. We don't have to. You've chosen to. I kind of do. Well, I am supportive and admiring, but I'm not sure that that's that's rebellion necessarily is it and it it uh segues neatly into a question from um alex shiphorst again who's absolutely on fire with his questions
我想说，目前刚刚出现的一种倾向是，素食主义已经侵入了我们的冰箱。所以这有点烦人，但显然我们必须对此给予支持。我们不必支持。是你自己选择支持的。我某种程度上确实支持。好吧，我是支持和赞赏的，但我不确定这是否必然算是一种叛逆，而且它很自然地过渡到了亚历克斯·希普霍斯特的另一个问题，他又一次带着极为犀利的问题闪亮登场了。
in this episode um i wondering whether historians in the future will look back at greta thunberg and see a is it thunberg isn't it a transformation in teenagerhood i one that is more politicized especially environmentally conscious. Perhaps a rebel with a cause. And I would say that that probably is true. But I'm aware that I'm saying that from the perspective of... No, I think you're probably right. I think...
在本期节目中，我想知道未来的历史学家在回看格蕾塔·通贝里时，是否会认为这是一个青少年时期的转变？一个更加政治化、特别是具备环保意识的转变。也许是一个有因之叛。我想说这大概是真的。但我意识到我是在从……的角度说这句话。不，我想你大概是对的。我认为……
I mean, the other thing I would extrapolate from my daughters is an absolute fascination with design, style, clothing, dress. But that's always been... So that does go back to... I mean, that would be recognisable to the readers of Seventeen magazine in 1944. But I think you're right that the... I buy Alex Shiphorse's question. I think it's a really interesting question about Greta Thunberg and the way in which she's become a kind of secular saint.
我的意思是，我从我的女儿们身上推断出的另一件事是对设计、风格、服装和穿搭的绝对着迷。但这一直都是……所以这确实可以追溯到……我的意思是，这对于1944年《十七》杂志的读者来说是完全可以理解的。但我认为你是对的，我赞同亚历克斯·希普霍斯特的问题。我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，关于格蕾塔·通贝里以及她如何成为某种世俗圣人。
I mean, we've got some questions about Joan of Arc, I know. And her youth and the fact that she's a sort of a girl or a young woman, I guess she's still a girl technically, who looks even younger than she is. I think that obviously plays a colossal part in her international appeal. But I suppose the danger with talking about teenagers and idealism, and I've always been very conscious of that in my own books about post-war Britain, is that it's very easy to be misled by the most articulate, the most highly educated. Yeah, that's a running theme for you, isn't it?
我的意思是，我知道我们有一些关于圣女贞德的问题。以及她的年轻，以及她是一个女孩或年轻女性的事实——我想她从技术上讲仍然是个女孩——她看起来比实际年龄还要年轻。我认为这在她的国际吸引力中显然起到了巨大的作用。但我想，谈论青少年和理想主义的危险在于——我在自己关于战后英国的书籍中一直对这一点深有体会——我们很容易被那些最能言善辩、受过最高教育的人误导。是的，这是你的一贯主题，对吧？
The peacocks, and I guess the peahens, if peahens had dramatic tales um they are they are more visually striking and so they're the ones who appear in the books and get the documentaries and yes here on the postcards and things whereas um i guess you'll tell me the vast majority never rebelled no they didn't kind of went to school went to university or got a job or and became adults and i mean my two sort of my one of my standard facts on this is when the Rolling Stones were busted by the police for drug possession and were sent to prison, Mick Jagger and Keith Richards. The Times published an editorial saying they had been unfairly punished and they should be let out. Who breaks a butterfly on a wheel. Exactly.
那些雄孔雀，我想还有雌孔雀，如果雌孔雀也有戏剧性的故事的话，它们在视觉上更加引人注目，所以它们才会出现在书中并被拍成纪录片，是的，还有明信片之类的主角，而我想你会告诉我，绝大多数人从未叛逆过。是的，他们没有。他们只是上学、上大学、找工作，然后成为成年人。我的意思是，我关于这个主题的一个标准事实是，当滚石乐队因藏毒被警方搜查并被判入狱时，米克·贾格尔和基思·理查兹。《泰晤士报》发表了一篇社论，称他们受到了不公正的惩罚，应该被释放。谁会用大锤砸死一只蝴蝶呢。没错。
Written by William Rees-Mogg. Father of. Yes. But opinion polls showed that young people themselves thought they should be imprisoned. So young people were not on the side of...
由威廉·里斯-莫格撰写。……的父亲。是的。但民意调查显示，年轻人自己却认为他们应该被关进监狱。所以年轻人并不站在……
It wasn't an old establishment versus a liberal younger generation. Actually, the younger generation were just as... And if you look at polls generally of young people in the 60s, they're very anti-immigration. They're very anti-student protests.
这不是老牌建制派与自由派年轻一代的对抗。实际上，年轻一代同样……如果你看看60年代年轻人的一般民意调查，他们非常反对移民。他们非常反对学生抗议。
They're very culturally conservative on lots of kind of moral issues. But isn't that, I mean, that's a crucial, because you're not just rebelling against your parents. You're also distinguishing yourself from your boring peers.
他们在许多道德问题上都极其文化保守。但难道不是吗？我的意思是，这是一个关键点，因为你不仅是在反叛父母。你还要将自己与那些无聊同龄人区分开来。
Yeah. And that's why you have the magazine. So if you're reading the right magazines and you're going to the right shops, that's where tribes come from. Yes. They're never a group. They're only homogenous.
是的。这就是为什么你会有杂志。所以如果你在阅读正确的杂志，去正确的商店，亚文化群体就是这样诞生的。是的。他们从来都不是一个整体。他们绝不单一。
Yeah, but perhaps the kind of teenage identity, the more it's percolated out the less opportunity there is to to rebel because basically everybody is wearing you know kind of rebellious clothing is no longer rebellious it doesn't have that kind of cachet yeah but also i wonder whether tom actually you're asking that question makes me wonder whether the sense of the teenager will have any, how long teenagers will exist for. So in other words, we can agree that adolescence existed before 1944, but teenagers have a history. They had a starting point. But you could argue that teenage culture will have an end point, especially as younger children now have more money as well.
是的，但也许青少年身份这种东西，它渗得越透彻，反叛的机会就越少，因为基本上每个人都在穿——你知道的，所谓的叛逆服装已经不再叛逆了，它不再具有那种声望了。是的，但我也在想，汤姆，你提出那个问题让我在想，青少年的这种概念会有任何……青少年还能存在多久。换句话说，我们可以同意青春期在1944年之前就存在，但青少年是有历史的。他们有一个起点。但你可以辩称，青少年文化也会有终点，尤其是现在年幼的孩子也有了更多的钱。
And the adults are, as you you say becoming kidults the very concept of a teenager seems less to have less yeah maybe yeah yeah so maybe it'll be a kind of interesting foible of sort of late 20th century culture and yeah i mean fascinating um i think we're closing to an end could i just put in uh one question, which is from an old friend of mine. And we met when we were teenagers. Oh, nice. Charlene,
而成年人正如你所说正在变成“大龄儿童”，青少年这个概念本身似乎越来越不具备——是的，也许吧，是的，所以也许这会是20世纪末文化中一个有趣的怪癖，是的，我的意思是，太迷人了。我想我们快要结束了，我能插播一个问题吗？来自我的一个老朋友。我们是在当青少年时认识的。哦，太好了，夏琳，
who has sent in a broad brush question. And she asks, it's just a given that teenagers think no adult understands them. So that's Kevin, the teenager. But which era was the very worst time to be a teenager and why? Wow. I mean, I guess the answer to that is the worst time to be a teenager is, you know, it's going to be the same for everyone.
她发来了一个宏观的问题。她问，青少年觉得没有成年人能理解他们，这简直是理所当然的。所以那是凯文式的青少年。但哪个时代做青少年是最糟糕的时期？为什么？哇。我的意思是，我想这个答案是，做青少年的最糟糕时期是——你知道的，对每个人来说都一样。
I mean, if you're being slaughtered by some invading army, it doesn't really make a difference. So there's no point in asking the question that way, is there? I suppose answering the question we should answer as in specifically a teenager rather than just you're in the middle of a war. Well, having said that, when the Persians stormed Miletus, the end of the Ionian revolt, early 5th century, all the adults were slaughtered. The girls were carried off to the harems the boys were castrated
我的意思是，如果你正被某个侵略军队屠杀，这其实没什么区别。所以没必要以那种方式提问，对吧？我想我们要回答的问题应该是专门作为青少年，而不是仅仅说你正处于战争之中。话虽如此，当波斯人攻陷米利都时，伊奥尼亚起义结束，公元前5世纪初，所有的成年人都被屠杀了。女孩们被掳到后宫，男孩们被阉割，
and carried off to be eunuchs and obviously genital mutilation has been a running theme in this this is the third podcast almost in a row so I think that would be bad I mean I wouldn't want to be a teenager yeah but that's not that's a specific
并被带去当太监。显然，生殖器切除一直是这个播客的连贯主题，这几乎是连续第三期节目了，所以我觉得那会很糟糕，我的意思是，我才不想当青少年呢。是的，但那不是一个具体的——
that's a bad bit of miletus that's a specific that's a bad bit of luck but it doesn't mean that the culture itself was anti-teenage does it i think if there's a moment when it's when the generation gap is well i mean britain in the early 80s i mean there were some schools in britain in the early 80s where they gave children lessons on how to sign on for the Dole in the summer term because they knew that almost all of them, 160 people would leave the school and there are only two jobs in the town. I mean, that's a pretty bad time to be a teenager. So I think the early 80s is probably economically
那是米利都的一次特定遭遇，那是一次特殊的倒霉，但这并不意味着文化本身是反青少年的，对吧？我想如果有一个代沟显著的时刻——我的意思是，80年代初的英国，我的意思是，英国80年代初有些学校在夏季学期教孩子们如何在失业救济金申请表上签字，因为他们知道几乎所有人，160个人都会离开学校，而镇上只有两份工作。我的意思是，那是做青少年的相当糟糕的时期。所以我认为80年代初可能在经济上
when massive youth unemployment, as bad as you could imagine. I mean, actually, that's been the situation in France for about the last 30 years, isn't it? They have 25% youth unemployment. And you wouldn't say that 1930s Germany would count as... We're not counting them as teenagers because the word hasn't been invented yet. Yeah, because I think it's also a bit of a special case, isn't it? I mean, I'm sure there must be people who... Well, the really interesting thing is there must have been people who lived through the Third Reich as teenagers,
青年失业率极高，能想象到的最糟糕的情况。我的意思是，实际上，这大约是法国过去30年来的状况，不是吗？他们的青年失业率高达25%。你不会说30年代的德国算作……我们不算他们是青少年，因为“青少年”这个词当时还没被发明出来。是的，因为我也觉得这也是个特例，不是吗？我的意思是，我确信一定有人……好吧，真正有趣的是，一定有人在第三帝国时期作为青少年度过了那段时光，
but perhaps just missed being called up to fight in the war right at the end, for whom their teenage years may not have actually been... They may not remember their teenage years specifically as terribly bad. If they were in a family that was supporting the Nazis and they weren't Jewish or anything like that. I mean, that's the sort of interesting and slightly disturbing thought
但可能刚好在快结束时错过了被征召去参战，对他们来说，青少年的岁月实际上可能并非……他们可能并不把自己的青少年时代记为极其糟糕。如果他们在一个支持纳粹的家庭里，而且他们又不是犹太人或诸如此类的人。我的意思是，这是一种有趣且略带不安的想法，
that these swing kids that we were talking about in Hamburg, was life terrible for them? Well, it was when the British were dropping bombs on them. I think it was terrible also because they were under constant risk of being raided by the Gestapo and sent to labour camps What's really interesting is that we always think of teenage
我们在汉堡谈到的那些摇摆青年，他们的生活很糟糕吗？嗯，当英国人向他们投掷炸弹时是的。我认为也很糟糕，因为他们时刻面临着被盖世太保突袭并送往劳改营的风险。真正有趣的是，我们总是认为青少年
we have tons of questions about this, about idealism but that idealism can often be very it's not always a good thing so idealism I mean lots of young people really enthusiastically supported the Nazis. There's a very famous account by a girl called Melita Mashman. And she talks about,
我们有很多关于这方面的问题，关于理想主义，但这种理想主义往往非常——它并不总是一件好事。所以理想主义——我的意思是，许多年轻人非常热烈地支持纳粹。有一个非常著名的自述，是一个叫梅利塔·马什曼的女孩写的。她谈到，
you know, she was a young girl in Berlin in January 1933, brimming with kind of teenage enthusiasm and teenage idealism. And she watches the torchlit parade. Hitler has just become Chancellor of Germany. And she is absolutely suffused with this love of country, desire to join the movement, all this sort of teenage idealism that we can recognise. And of course, it's utterly misapplied into this obscene project. But the idea that teenagers properly are idealistic, I mean, that's another legacy of the French Revolution, isn't it? I mean, we talked about this, about how so many of the revolutionaries were very, very young.
你知道的，1933年1月，她是柏林的一个年轻女孩，充满了那种青少年的热情和青少年的理想主义。她看着火炬游行。希特勒刚刚成为德国总理。她完全沉浸在这种对国家的爱中，渴望加入这个运动，所有这些我们都能认同的青少年的理想主义。当然，它被完全错置到了这个骇人听闻的计划中。但青少年天生就具有理想主义这种想法，我的意思是，这也是法国大革命的另一个遗产，不是吗？我的意思是，我们讨论过这个，关于那么多革命者是多么的年轻。
And I guess it blends with the Romantic period where lots of the poets are very young as well. I think that's where that idea comes from. Because certainly the premise for earlier periods through the Middle Ages back to the ancient world is that people we would now call teenagers are essentially feral and dangerous and have to be broken in and tamed and dis... Well, on that note, I think that's the perfect note on which to end. I didn't even like teenagers when I was a teenager. The man they cannot gag, he knows he's been there. That's William Hague. That's William Hague.
我想这与浪漫主义时期交融在一起，那时的许多诗人也很年轻。我想这就是这种想法的来源。因为当然，从中世纪到古代世界早期阶段的前提是，我们现在所称的青少年本质上是野蛮的、危险的，必须被打破和驯服以及压制……好吧，顺便说一句，我认为这是结束本期节目的绝佳音符。我当青少年时甚至都不喜欢青少年。那个谁也封不住嘴的人，他心里清楚自己经历过。那是威廉·黑格。那是威廉·黑格。
That was William Hague's slogan when he was writing a column for the News of the World. Where has he been? Nowhere. What happened to him? He'd been to Richmond. That was about it, I think. I think that's the perfect note, isn't it? On which to end?
那是威廉·黑格为《世界新闻报》撰写专栏时的标语。他去过哪里？哪里也没去。他怎么了？他去过里士满。大概也就是这样吧，我想。我认为这是个完美的结语，不是吗？最适合结束的时刻？
Yeah, it is. It is. The super teenage, saw-away episode. William Hague, of course, did come to fame as a teenager. That's why I mentioned him, Dominic. Yeah. You should always try to end every podcast on William Hague or other failed Tory leaders. This is the podcast that has a theme on teenagers and ends with William Hague.
是的，确实如此。这是超级青少年、锯木般的特别一期。威廉·黑格当然是以青少年的身份成名的。这就是我提到他的原因，多米尼克。是的。你总是应该试着在每一期播客结束时谈到威廉·黑格或其他失败的保守党领袖。这就是这个以青少年为主题并以威廉·黑格结束的播客。
Thanks ever so much for listening. We will see you in a few days where we are talking about the Aztecs. And we have some quite interesting details about children and young people in the Aztec period so do tune in then. Gentle mutilation once again see you and gentle mutilation see you then bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
非常感谢大家的收听。我们在几天后会再次与大家见面，届时我们将讨论阿兹特克人。我们在阿兹特克时期关于儿童和年轻人有一些相当有趣的细节，所以请务必届时收听。再次提到生殖器切除，再见，还有生殖器切除，回见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。